Carl it's great to be with you and great
to be talking about your book circle of
greed what I wanted to do is ask you
first what would prompted you to write
this book because you were White House
correspondent your last book about
President Bush co-written with your
father who of course covered and was
wrote the definitive biography of
President Reagan I mean that book made a
world of sense this book is fascinating
book but what prompted you to write this
book about Bill Dirac well actually
each book was prompted by the same
initial foray a friend of mine one case
my father in the other case my co-author
Patrick Dillon called me up and said we
ought to do a book and when lukannon
asked you to do a book with him about
presidents there was only one answer
even if you're not his son it's yes but
in this case Patrick Dylan my longtime
friend from California called me on the
phone and said we should do a book about
Bill Dirac and my first I had turned in
the galleys we've gone over the galleys
that day on the reagan book the last my
dad and I the Reagan's disciple it's
called the book the book which we
compared in George W Bush to Ronald
Reagan and I told Pat I had I have a
succinct answer for you no I'm never
doing another book in my life but that
gets to the question you really answer
so why did I want to do this well build
Iraq was the most compelling lawyer I
ever covered and I thirty years ago when
I was assigned to the courts in San
Diego has a very junior reporter and Pat
Dylan was a city editor I came that this
guy walked through the literally in the
halls of justice and San Diego in the
courtroom and I kind of knew right away
nothing was ever gonna be the same
he was then very thin and had this wild
blond afro but he had an idea that that
the law and Cal Southern California San
Diego particularly but all of securities
law was a sleepy backwater and he was
going to change it and the first big
case that he took was he sued the United
Methodist Church in a class-action suit
and everybody including his partner Mel
Weiss thought he was crazy
and but he wasn't anyone anyone
twenty-one million dollars and he and I
went back to the city room and I said
that my newspaper I said this guy we got
to cover this guy and so thirty years
later
that sort of called me on my on my
prediction and said you have to help me
write this book okay now he bill Iraq
obviously did a lot of things since you
first met him didn't just sue the
Methodist Church and he ended up getting
some verdicts eventually that were
substantially north of twenty-one
million dollars so tell me a little bit
about why Bill Iraq is not just
interesting but why is it why is he
important well he he and Mel Weiss
perfected as you know because you you
later in this later in my story and
later in the bills story you you came
across this and wrote a brief when you
were in the Solicitor General's when you
were the Solicitor General but for our
our listeners and I won't be giving away
everything they perfected this idea of
class action securities lawsuits and
when we say securities we mean stocks
people you own stock everybody owns
stock you can't help but now if you have
a 401 K you own stock and in the old
days when just some rich people owned a
little bit of Wall Street this wouldn't
have been an issue but with the advent
of the stock market becoming the thing
that everybody was in whoever you were
any working person in this country there
became not a few thousand shareholders
but millions of shareholders and when
their stock went down they would get
upset they were stock wasn't supposed to
go down but it does sometimes but in the
late nineteen seventies in early
nineteen eighties a funny thing would
happen if you are in a company where
your stock went down you would
immediately be sued and a huge
class-action lawsuit by an array of
firms but the number one firm was
Milberg Weiss and they perfected this
this art now of suing now if you were a
corporate guy it was a dark art it was
black magic it was an awful sort of
thing but if you were a shareholder
maybe you liked it somebody was sticking
up for you but they and over the course
of the next twenty five years they were
responsible Milberg Weiss which is bill
directs firm and its imitators and
partners with about collecting about
forty billion dollars we think in money
from companies that have been sued and
transferring it to shareholders then as
you know taking a healthy cut for
themselves off the
and they're responsible in the process
for doing a number of things right I
mean they I think and maybe you can say
a few words about this I think bill
Dirac may be more responsible than any
other single person for making Silicon
Valley a political force well oh that's
true although maybe getting a little out
of our story there he you know the
subtitle of this book is the lawyer who
brought corporate America to its knees
they sued every company Paul that you've
heard of and some of them any company
I've ever worked for they sue them is
right they sued AOL they sued Time
Warner they sued Disney multiple times
they soon you look Packard an Apple and
IBM and all of the companies and and
what what what happened in those days
was the Silicon Valley was just getting
started it was becoming this great
engine of productivity and wealth I mean
it changed change the world that the
microchip changed every human endeavor
but along that will end along the way
the the people who made Silicon Valley
what it was became fantastically rich
now and and their stock would go up and
down it was a very volatile time no it's
a volatile industry because you're if
you get an advance of three weeks on a
technology you give it a lot of it's
worth a lot of money to the market and
so there was this constant pressure to
come up with the next killer app they
call it in the valley and and these guys
got a lot of leeway in the press they
got a lot of leeway from me the question
the question that arises is were they
doing funny things or they namely
insider trading right bill Iraq will
tell you that invariably they were doing
not the things and he doesn't think
they're funny he's a true believer he
thinks they're crooked and he would call
these routinely call these people
fraudsters and frauds and he corporate
fraud to him as a corporates and
modifier of the word fraud or vice versa
and what he did was he sued these
companies and they become under this
pressure to settle these cases and these
they were called strike suits initially
then turn Bill Iraq hates but
popularized by Chris Cox a congressman
who later became head
the SEC but they were just your stock
would go down and boom there'd be a
lawsuit on your desk for millions right
and the people would say well you know
this was beyond her control you know the
Japanese that came to the market with
something a few days ahead of us will be
back well there I could say no you
committed fraud you told investors that
everything was good and they'd go
through your corporate statements and
your public relations statements and
your statements to investors and then he
would look and see if you had dumped a
bunch of stock beforehand or your
in-laws had and suddenly you're on the
hook for millions of dollars so what
began to happen was these suits got to
be settled rarely went to trial right no
and it's interesting too because when I
ask you a little bit more about the
racks kind of background on what makes
him tick but one thing that's
interesting is when you first saw him in
that case against the Methodist Church
he was a terrific trial lawyer right now
later in his career he never spent any
time himself in court and what can you
talk a little bit about what what what
transition kind of happened there what
what was the transition from being
basically a trial lawyer to more of a
kind of a manager of tremendous
quantities of litigation well that's it
that's a very interesting and dramatic
story a couple of things happen the
first thing that happened was as these
suits became it became much more
profitable it became in the interest of
these companies to settle the lawsuits
without going to trial sure why one
reason because these guys had seen this
guy had taken on the Methodist Church in
one he took on this aura of
invincibility which turned out to be
well it was punctured but for a while
nobody wanted to go to trial with this
guy and he was very very adamant I want
to go to trial and tell these guys he's
yelling at me threaten them I will own
your house in Maui I will put you out of
business your kids will go back to
public school he would be rate these
wealthy CEOs to their faces and their
lawyers would just want to strangle him
but you as you know Paul you you can't
do that in a deposition strangling stuff
for them there's no R on our tests in
the law and anyway so they began to
settle and another reason they settled
may be the primary reason is the system
was rigged in a way that helped
it was like a plea-bargain kind of
incentive in criminal courts directors
and officers insurance dno insurance all
the you had to go get it sure after Iraq
came along you had to have it and that
indemnifies the corporate officers and
managers against the personal somebody
going after their personal wealth
understandable but those policies have
to be written in a way that if you're if
if you committed fraud they can't
protect you because for a lot of reasons
but they would be defrauding then the
company that was insuring them so these
good but Lautrec was always alleging
fraud he wasn't alleging bad management
these guys so you have the double whammy
they don't really want to go to trial
trial is expensive it's time-consuming
and give them the benefit the doubt they
want to do their business they want to
make semiconductors or IMAX or they want
to make their these magical new products
they don't want some lawyer rifling
through their papers and spending and
then running up their own legal fees so
they don't want the lawsuit first they
don't want to loss it at all they're
afraid of good trial losing and then
finally they're dno insurance won't
protect them if they lose so all of
these all of these pressures made them
settle the cases routinely
but as they settle them for increasingly
large amounts they began to hate bill
Dirac they began to demonize him and
blame him and I'm Chris Cox compared him
to Al Capone at a congressional hearing
Al Shugart said he wanted to kill him
these this guy his name became a verb to
get more Act the law that in 1995 when
the Republicans took over the house and
they move and the Senate moved
immediately to curb these strike suits
it was called it was dubbed on the hill
to get an Iraq act so he became an
important person and and you debt you
asked earlier and I I didn't mention it
but now I should and and in partisan
politics too Bill's a Democrat he gave a
lot of money to Democrats the trial
lawyers became identified but but this
was all happening in this period of time
and it was happening in in large part
over these suits you know in those days
the Republicans of Ronald Reagan used to
talk about tort reform okay you know
this and he in some of the examples they
would
seems so quaint today a guy sued for a
BMWs paint scratched he got 1.8 million
a woman spilled a cup of coffee on
McDonald's and she got you know millions
well that's not what was really driving
this what was driving the get LaRocca
act the Private Securities Litigation
Reform Act of 1995 a law aimed at nobre
twice was these shakedown suits that's
how they viewed him sure sure Sevilla
RAC is somebody who got Congress to
respond to him as we talked a little bit
about earlier he'd sort of awakened the
sleeping giant in Silicon Valley I mean
those companies typically did not get
involved in politics before they kind of
unified around the idea of trying to
fight his lawsuits and kind of curb him
so this this is a guy who's really I
mean a lot of ripples have gone out from
these lawsuits that he's filed so before
we talk more about kind of the
consequences I mean what makes this guy
tick I mean how does a guy what kind of
a middle class guy from Pittsburgh end
up living in San Diego in a mansion and
striking fear in Silicon Valley in
corporate America well part of the
reason I grew up in California and every
every year there would be on the Rose
Bowl that'd be beautiful weather and the
team from usually Ohio State would come
out there Michigan and you see them
looking around it's New Year's Day and
they'd say why am I going been going
back to a while and Bill had that
experience he came out to California to
do a case and he looked around he
thought this is where I want to be so
that part of it is in ways typical but
easy for a Californian to understand and
graduate but there was an atypical part
of this of his makeup he is a very
competitive guy and he's made for the
arena and we all know lawyers like this
he he he's father his father was a
middle manager in Pittsburgh bill later
would have a story around his family
life that's some of it's true and some
of its embellished the way all of our
stories are about his father was ruined
in the great depression he formed these
roosevelt ian views of capitalism as if
Roosevelt didn't really like capitalism
but I digress his father is his father
was a middle manager in a Country Club
Republican his brother
was general counsel for US Steel for
many years bill was on that trajectory
even after his dad died tragically bill
and he went out he was in high school
they played a game of golf his father
went home laid down and never got up it
was a very big blow but bill went on he
went to Pitt law school he got a job
with a white-shoe law firm there in
Pittsburgh but during that he handled a
few defense cases but he was the guy
it's like in football you know you're
supposed to protect the quarterback and
you realize you really want to kill him
and you ask the coach could I go to the
defensive line bill wanted to attack he
wanted to sue he wanted to litigate he
wanted to stick up and in his mind you
stick up for little people yeah and I
think that's a part of it it really is
he wanted to be the guy going up against
Goliath and taking their money and and
filing suits and finding out the detail
in that in the case that would turn it
in your favor the Perry Mason of civil
law and when he found and so and so he
left that law firm and he he left but he
left that firm after meeting mal Weiss
and mal is a guy from New York up from
the streets guy whose father was an
accountant and whose and they wanted
well it was expected to be an accountant
but he tried it but he went in the arm
and he came out he thought he didn't
want to be a cop you want to be a lawyer
he wanted a good liberal strongest stick
up for civil rights be a lawyer and with
the night school he came out but turned
out Mel Weiss learned something from his
dad the accountant he was really good
with numbers
that time working after school his dad's
firm really stuck and Mel as Mel got
into a few stikat a few civil cases that
just came in over the transom he could
spot cheating the corporate cheating and
Mel figured out that the law that was
the class action the federal rules that
that helped make it easier to bring
class-action suits on behalf of people I
like the insulated and brown versus
Topeka Kansas and some of these other
great iconic lawsuits they could be used
for shareholders to to sue companies and
the rules had been changed and Mel
thought you could do this and so bill
went out to Denver they met and the
racket found his muse he wanted to do
what
I was doing and they became this force
in Securities Litigation and in their
minds not just then to this day it was
giving a speech on on Capitol Hill this
month that they are sticking up for the
little guy and going after corporate
corruption corporate fraud on behalf of
small investors and that became their
crusade and I mean let me ask the
question this way which is I suppose one
could write a book about Mel Weiss and I
mean Milberg Weiss was also a very
high-profile law firm you know with Bill
Iraq as a partner and then later without
bill the rackets partner why write a
book about Bill Iraq and and not know
why it's what makes what makes Bill sort
of a more interesting character
he's a lightning rod he's a poet he's
one of these well the first answer
question is because somebody may write a
book about Mellon I don't want to
prejudge that I mean you know you could
write a book about Gehrig or you could
write a book about Ruth you could write
a book about both them but you know
what's his name David McCullough wanted
to write a book about the friendship
between Adams and Jefferson and they
said he didn't like Jefferson well
enough so they're writing John Adams
well guess what it's one of the big
prize it would have made him a very
wealthy man so some part that's just
subjective we knew bill we decided to
write about him but but but he's the guy
there is there's something about a guy
yeah even though but he he was a
follower of Mel Weiss yeah I mean you
know it was the get LaRocca it wasn't
the get Mel Weiss well he yeah and and
the reasons for that you know he has a
charismatic person for one thing and
people and he's a polarizing person
people paid him people also love him he
is really he's got people oh I mean
there were people when he was in prison
who said when this when the financial
meltdown could get bill out of prison
he'll fix this mm-hmm that's the kind of
faith some people have in him and he's
also it's also a good friend to people
and a hell of an enemy larger than life
guy we knew him we had access to him I
don't you know and and and that's
probably worth talking about for a
minute Paul here's a guy he's convicted
we start this book after he
was pled guilty right and we knew him we
had a lot of string on I still had files
on him from I wasn't found him in my
garage but and he cooperated and he
cooperated in a way that I don't care
who you are what your politics are
pretty admirable didn't didn't didn't
try and shape the book particularly
right sir to our questions right would
give his best view but and never asked
to see a word of it before I was
published not a word right so this is no
authorized biography this is and and he
knew that at least you know you in
particular we're coming at this with
subscript it's ISM right yeah he he knew
us and trusted our work and I but but
yeah I was
I don't I probably sided with the
Silicon Valley guys more than the
plaintiffs lawyers in this in my mind
over the years but my coverage had been
pretty straight but yeah I was skeptical
and and remember let's go back to that
if you're on the receiving end of one of
these suits with all that we did to talk
to bill with the with the pressure to
settle with the terrible time it would
take you to defend the suit it just
seems like a shakedown to you it seems
like a legalized extortion that's how
they saw it that's how it felt to them
and that's how they characterized it
when they struck back sure sure
well just let's get can there's a middle
part of the story here we're missing
because you alluded to the fact that
this fighter a fraud this crusader for
the little guy spent some time in the
federal penitentiary yeah now it seems a
little anomalous right I mean somebody
is out there accusing others of
wrongdoing and then in the process ends
up pleading to a federal felony so can
you just fill us in I mean how does this
how does this crusader end up being on
the wrong side of the V you know in
United States versus Loretta well let me
give you first the bare details and then
we can discuss maybe the implications of
it the moral dimension
Milberg Weiss was always first to the
courthouse these people began imitating
what they were doing oh IBM stock has
dropped and they just said they were it
was gonna go up we'll sue them will they
get there well sorry boys
he'll request Authority they've already
filed they filed yesterday right and
just to clarify it's in the nature of a
class action
kind of uniquely and not everybody may
understand this but it's in the you Nate
the nature of a class action that really
you're suing one one lawyer is going to
end up suing for the entire class of
shareholders so it's not like a
situation where in a normal lawsuit well
I might have a client you might have a
client we're suing the same defendant
this there really is in a sense a race
to the courthouse exact because there's
only going to be one big class action
against some company who stopped just
went like that's right and the judge
certifies the class is what it's called
and then has to appoint a lawyer and the
lawyer is usually the person who was
there first in those days although that
itself came under attack business model
but but what but you do have to have a
client at least a named client and what
you do is you typically would file on
behalf of one person or more wonderful
eight or ten and then say and everybody
else that was affected judge would look
at your complaints well it seems to be
in order and it almost always was with
Milberg Weiss because they had an
assembly line in fact every once in a
while though this suit wasn't in order
they they would rush to the courthouse
so fast they would leave the previous
plaintiffs name on the lawsuit and this
would became it's kind of funny but in
the Silicon Valley people would tear
their hair out and screaming you know
why isn't anybody paying attention uh
see this is just a racket but anyway but
it turns out there was a reason and one
of the reasons was that they had
Melbourne Weiss was this finely oiled
machine and they kept meticulous records
and they watched the stock and they were
ready to pounce and they became the you
know the best-in-show the other reason
was and this was what you were asking me
about well they had some stalking horses
they had some professional plaintiffs
they had a whole stable of guys with
colorful names like Seymour Lazar and
Steve Cooperman who were later convicted
art theft who would buy stock only so
that they could sue the company and that
in itself isn't a crime it's very
dubious and you would have thought the
federal judges would have wised up to it
faster than they did but what Milberg
Weiss was doing what Bill lorac was
doing was giving kickbacks to these guys
for their suits total your unrelated to
their own personal losses
more to how much the firm recovered
mm-hmm this was against the law
there are apologists of bills and in
fact if this was a normal c-span show or
you could call in we would hear somebody
calling and they would say oh it wasn't
really against the law but Paul you and
I know it was always against the law was
against the federal rules of evidence
and the code and it was the law and it
was the common law and in fact just to
be sure it's often almost invariably
federal judges would ask guys under oath
like Seymour Lazar did you get any
special money did you get no so no your
honor well so they committed perjury and
Milberg wife's committed fraud and that
was what and eventually a a federal
prosecutor in Los Angeles in Robinson
got on to it many prosecutors it took
seven years to bring this case to trial
some of bills friends and Bill himself
occasionally will say well you know Dick
Cheney was after me because of
Halliburton but actually this case
predated the Bush administration huh
in Robinson's office and Robinson
himself is a Democrat and I used to play
in a rock and roll band he's kind of an
eclectic
he seems like a Daniel Moynihan Democrat
to me I've never asked him his politics
but he's not he's not a Republican at
all but he's a lawyer and he's a civil
servant and he thought this crime had
been committed and it was wrong and
other people and people were being
disadvantaged and this long prosecution
began that led to bills pleading guilty
and now Weis pleading guilty and the
firm paying a big fine and other people
going to jail and the breakup of this
ring right so that is really a fall from
grace and just to be clear about the the
practice that they were engaged in I
mean they're it's you know some people
might think of this as a victimless
crime but I mean or at least one of the
victims of this crime the other people
in the lawsuit who you know the whole
idea of a class action is you're
supposed to participate equally with all
the other shareholders and their
recovery and here it is a couple of
these shareholders who are in cahoots
with the law firm are getting huge
kickbacks that's right and that and
that's and that's why and that's why
it's a crime because if it's a class
you're supposed to [ __ ] you're supposed
to share the
according to your losses if you had
$100,000 of ash of a in stock and in a
company AOL I'll say they use my company
and the company was found in the biller
and Bill Iraq settled well you would get
some whatever the share was a pro-rated
share you're a hundred thousand where
was fifteen cents on the dollar whatever
you get 15 grand a guy had a hundred
bucks would you know get fifteen dollars
but if a guy had one five hundred
dollars with the share and he got thirty
or forty or seven six or seven hundred
grand obviously that's not cool
it's it's its own kind of fraud there
was another there's but there's a
secondary victim here I don't that words
overused in our society but how about
the lawyers who were doing it honestly
mm-hmm and I you're a lawyer you're
honest lawyer so you know what I'm
talking about i guy be the source on
this book and I became friends friendly
with and I respect a great deal Sean
coffee lawyer in New York was running
for attorney general he he's he tangled
with bill because he said you know first
of all you're giving us a bad name but
secondly you're disadvantaging other
firms and that and that you know well
it's hard to win a race to the
courthouse when the other side's got an
unlawful and unfair head start that's
true and and but and it's funny Congress
when Congress went after Bill Iraq and
my wife's in their whole model they the
testimony you can see it today it's
interesting they suspected something
like this was gone but they didn't know
what sure they ask these kind of
questions or you know multiple you want
multiple clients do you were well yeah
occasionally sure bill says you know guy
likes my work you'll come back to me but
they kind of knew there was some the
game was rigged somehow they didn't
quite know how right and what it was you
know it was this prosecution the case
that unraveled all that sure because I
mean when Congress passed the getler act
act the Private Securities Litigation
Reform Act I mean they had no idea that
lorac was involved in actual criminal
conduct I mean they were really aiming
at the at the
he was going about putting these
lawsuits together actually I think some
of these Republicans did have an idea
they just didn't know how he was doing
it mm-hmm but there was such antipathy
on both sides you know bill was painted
as the bad guy but bill didn't take that
lying down in his view the bad guy with
his corporate fraudsters mm-hmm and in
that cell very same testimony on the
gala rack that where bill kind of shaded
the truth on how these some of his
tactics he issued a very blunt morning
to these guys he says you remember the
Republicans had taken over the house the
first time I mean our in our lifetime
and a lot of things they wanted to do
the contract with america but one of
them was help their pals in corporate
america and even things up a little bit
the trailers and get bill or acted you
know you go after him but bill but we
just come out of the S&M crisis a few
years before and bill says to these guys
open testimony he says you can do this
if you want but if you do corporate
fraud will become so rampant you will
that you will look back on the SNL you
look back fondly on the S&L crisis it
will seem like a picnic to you and you
know in some in some ways that
prediction came true and there are
people in this city and places in this
book where we give bill his say on that
he predicted that reining in these
lawsuits the way Congress did and later
the courts did was going to have a
deleterious effect it was gonna
disadvantage investors it was gonna put
too much power again and in corporate
CEOs who had nobody really looking over
their shoulder or calling them to
account sure well let's talk more about
that after the break great
afterwards and several other c-span
programs are available for download as
podcasts more with Carl cannon and Paul
Clement in a moment consumer advocate
and four-time presidential candidate
Ralph Nader is our guest Sunday on book
TVs in-depth he's written more than 20
books from his first unsafe at any speed
in 1965 to corporate power in America
and a novel only the super-rich can save
us join our three-hour conversation on
consumer protection corporate
accountability and political activism
with your calls emails and tweets for
Ralph Nader Sunday at noon eastern on
c-span to's book TV
book TV is asking what are you reading
this summer book TV now has over 40,000
followers on Twitter and we're asking
them what's on their summer reading
lists Hz for freedom is reading George
Washington's sacred fire brown girl
speaks just finished reading Lola
Shannon's the secret lives of Baba
Saudis wives and that she's reading who
fears death by nnedi okorafor Admiral
Apocalypse is reading The Selfish Gene
by Richard Dawkins and noni Pocahontas
is reading Dean where's black postcards
follow us on twitter at book TV and tell
us what you're reading and we may
include your tweets in our weekend
programming
afterwards with Carl cannon Paul Clement
continues Carl I wanted to pick up right
where we left off and ask you about what
what seems to be something of a
contradiction about Bill Iraq I mean as
you mentioned earlier here's this person
who is the champion of the little guy I
mean that's as you know when you asked
him kind of about you know his approach
to these lawsuits he really talked about
being in there for the for the little
guy whether it's the the the elderly
individuals that were defrauded by the
Methodist Church in his first lawsuit or
just the kind of small stockholder who's
being defrauded in corporate America and
in in loraq sides so of course in the
process of being the champion of the
little guy Laraque gets to be the big
guy I mean he ends up making a fortune
you have one beautiful kind of vignette
in the book where he's walking on the
beach in San Diego and he looks up and
spies the largest mansion in all of La
Jolla and he says to himself you know
I'm gonna buy that and and he does
because he makes himself a multi-million
heir in the process of bringing these
lawsuits so can you talk about that I
mean you know whatever else you think
about these lawsuits some people
complain that the shareholders only
getting pennies on the dollars we know
at least one person was making up pretty
well in these lawsuits and that was
loraq that's right he and Mel Weiss
became fantastically rich there's no way
around it and and is that does that
undermine their message to some people
it did they some people said he's just
rationalizing this he and in time built
and a lot more money than the CEOs he
was suing typically and he became you
know it it's almost a metaphysical did
he become what he hated mmm-hmm
Nietzsche said if you're gonna fight
monsters be careful you don't become a
monster now I we write in the book
there's no monster but that is he
obviously the the wealth was a factor it
was an animating factor the money there
were there were cases there was
a guy from named Ted Roth a Democrat
from San Diego who had a small little
firming 20 people high tech firm they
were trying to bring something that
would help you I think blood helped
separate blood platelets I can't
remember exactly the technical thing and
there was an FDA test that was delayed
in their stock when dr. bill hit him
with strike suit but Ted knew the guy
his daughter had spent the night at
Bill's house because their daughters are
the same age and were friends in school
they knew each other from democratic
politics in San Diego and Ted went into
Bill and said we're not doing anything
come don't sue us but send a guy go
through our books do anything you want
but you know with and didn't I don't
care about the merits if you want talk
settlement let's talk settlement and it
was encounters like that that made even
people who had been disposed to look
like Bill Ted did like bill and had
shared his politics thought he lost his
way mm-hmm well another sort of I mean
that that quote sort of came back to
haunt Iraq a little bit and it's
something I think that motivated a lot
of people on the on the opposite side in
Silicon Valley and the rest I mean you
know if you're the champion of the
little guy you're supposed to care about
the merits it's not you know it's not
supposed to be about something else
another quote that came back to haunt
Bill Iraq a little bit was his quote to
the effect of you know I've the greatest
legal job in the world
I have no clients right how do you how
do you be the champion of the little guy
when in fact instead of having little
guys as your clients you have you have
no clients well that yeah that quote was
used against pillow a lot and heard him
but I gave let's give him the benefit of
doubt on that let's say what he's really
saying is I don't have any meddlesome
clients and they're telling me how to
run my case and bothering me I can run
the case the way I want
so one level the comments innocent but
on another one it points to the problem
you you said as in the end that you
asked about earlier as bill got out of
litigation and he became this became
almost a factor he became a CEO himself
they had they had they had this there's
this war room where they would produce
these lawsuits in bulk and they would
have people would handle the filing of
the lawsuit the other people the
depositions and other people the the
settlement and
the other one lawyer just the paperwork
of the settlement after had been agreed
to making sure that it was filed in a
way that didn't cost them thousands of
dollars in interests because it was a
human this was a it was a business mall
and a plant in an industry and Bill was
the CEO of it so he got further away
from the little people he got away from
the clients and I would suggest you
don't want to get away from the clients
and this was something that bill I I
think he wrestled with in and one of the
one of the things he would die if he was
sitting here was that that Milberg
wasted a lot of pro bono work and and
they did and some of it was was good
work they went to the Marianas and they
closed down some sweatshops well they
didn't close now they got they got
settlements they got money paid for the
people who who were doing this work and
so but they fought the tobacco industry
they did a lot of things that from their
standpoint showed that they were really
good guys and hadn't lost their way if
you're critical of them you might say
they were ameliorating their consciences
but the the question about can you be of
can you accumulate this kind of wealth
and not lose your way and not lose sight
of what you set out to do you know
that's a metaphysical question in fact
it's a religious question and Jesus
Christ spoke to it it's it's a very
profound problem and if to be to be good
to get that rich suing people and have
that kind of incentive to sue them you
almost have to come to think they're bad
you develop a manichaean worldview you
almost have to yes and I guess the other
thing that's a little bit I think you
know questionable about this whole
system if you take a step back is you
know why is it since there were lawyers
lining up to bring these lawsuits and
after a while for at least the Milberg
wisest and the racks of the world these
are relatively easy lawsuits to bring I
mean and sort of do the stock chart but
other than that as you suggested they
kind of have the complaint on the shelf
from their last case that they're
bringing and yet they're getting so much
money and the people who actually
invested the legitimate investors are
getting much less money in a sense
they're they're making out less the
shareholder than the lawyers that are
bringing these actions you know that a
rational system for
for compensating people who have lost
their money in the market it's not the
most efficient system is it rational no
not even but you know democracy is often
inefficient and irrational it really
ought to happen is the SEC on a run net
there to crack down on these guys and
put them in and you and there ought to
be a whole section Justice Department
makes this so so onerous to get caught
defrauding your own company that nobody
would do it that's probably a better
system any the system we have build Iraq
used to send these blistering letters to
Arthur Levitt when he ran the sec
calling him names and making fun of him
daring him to crack down on corporate
fraud but of course if Arthur Levitt had
done that bill those the business would
have dried up but that's not Bill's
fault and I don't in this I don't blame
the securities class action lawyers I
don't so I don't blame the plaintiffs
lawyers there was a system there that
they didn't create it really and what
they did was they tried to get some
money for their investors and I I'll say
two things about that first of all some
money is better than no money you lost
in the stock market because of fraud and
secondly the system itself on its face
seems goofy all right you get you get
together a hundred thousand people in
your class and they've lost their losses
range from due to fraud from forty bucks
to half a million and you settle me all
right with a seven million dollar
settlement I'll take it the lawyer says
a guy lost 40 bucks gets in what two
bucks the dial ossified hundred thousand
gets you know very enough to you know
pay his mortgage for six months so they
and then lawyer gets of the seven
million two million it sounds crazy but
this was the system of contingency that
exists in all plaintiffs bar and you
know as well as I do there's a rationale
for it and the rationale is you're
putting up all this money up front to
handle the case if you lose I'm gonna
talk about the lawyer now you don't get
in it you have to hire the experts you
have to develop the expertise you have
to carry it carry the freight of having
a law office and paying law clerks and
secretaries and other law
and that's the system and it's it's
about as inefficient system as you could
possibly design but what what's going to
take its place I mean you got to have
some recourse it seems to me for
investors if the SEC is dragging its
feet if the Supreme Court has made it
very hard to sue third party you know
the accounting firms that help the banks
steal the money you can't sue them
what's what what's the investor got
that's all the guys yeah it's not a
great system but it may be better than
nothing oh it's certainly better than
nothing I just wonder if maybe you know
instead of having a race to the
courthouse maybe the maybe the judges
should pick the counsel by the by the
law firm that's qualified that'll do it
for the least and get the most to the to
the shareholder well that's an
interesting idea Paul now under the
public securities reform litigation Act
PSLRA they get Barak act the race to the
courthouse was supposed to not be the
deal anymore
I wasn't here relevant they didn't
completely throw it out but there were
these other factors mainly how much
money you lost the law firm that had the
big the people really lost was supposed
to be the firm the law firm with the
most expertise though the law is it's
not as precise as you'd like but it it
changed the equation and it and it
worked in that extense in one way but
not the way the House Republicans
intended because as it made these suits
tougher to bring and the real thing it
did was changed the burden of proof
you couldn't just allege fraud you had
to have some evidence of fraud right
that was the big reform well then these
margin law firms well this thing's not
gonna you know this may be more trouble
that's worth these losses they used to
be easy now they're hard so that we've
got mill Bert Weiss out there beating us
to the courthouse anyway and they got
the bigger client and so what happened
was it actually helped him over twice
the get LaRocca did not get larec it
just changed his business model little
yeah and it made it much more efficient
for him he began getting big
institutional investors like pension
funds and the University of California
employees unions and need I say
democratic connected entities and then
said and had less competition more time
developed an expertise became the lead
counsel on Enron in other cases because
and in time
would take their lawsuit there
presentation of federal judge it would
be hard to turn them down they were
getting cases even after they were a
criminal investigation by judges who
knew they were under criminal
investigation because their law firm was
so good sure and I guess that goes back
to something you said before the break
though I think you suggested that
perhaps the the the the securities law
Reform Act of 1996 the PSLRA as we
lawyers like to call it you know and and
some other phenomena might have been
responsible for you know the events of
the last couple of September's and the
subprime crisis and the like but I mean
the PSLRA when it was passed when
Congress passed this act it didn't mean
that these lawsuits went away it just
you know it shifted the names of the
plaintiffs it shifted them around a
little bit but there were still plenty
of securities class actions being
brought between 1996 and 2007 yes you're
right it did lessen the number of
lawsuits but yeah you you can't say that
they made it illegal to sue but look
whole books have been written about the
subprime crisis in the housing bubble
and this book is not about this it's
more a narrative about these lawyers but
one of the factors I one of the factors
was that it was hot that led to the
breakdown in regulation clearly was the
Securities Exchange Commission wasn't
tough enough it wasn't you know Bernie
Madoff was brought to the attention by
the Boston office the Boston office has
a historic place in Securities
Litigation they're the one who spotted
the initial fraud back in the 30s that
led to the led to the law the Securities
Act that allows these suits in to begin
with fast forward to 2005 2004 this
complaint it's it's spotted the
attention by a person in the office it's
brought to their attention that they
dismiss it they don't do anything about
Madoff in their chapter and verse on
that they weren't doing their job the
second part of it was and you you
participate in this litigation but but
yeah but that I want to get their out
yeah yeah yeah but you know I think it's
it's worth given the SEC its do in the
following sense which is their jobs hard
because they're not like the
class-action securities lawyers waiting
until in every instance they're not
their idea isn't that they wait until
there's been a disaster and then they
come in and try to compensate the
shareholders who have lost after the
after the fraud has already been
manifested on the market I mean they're
trying to uncover unknown frauds and
trying to get at that and you can see
how difficult that is in your own book
by the fact that this prosecutor in Los
Angeles who's trying to uncover the
fraud that's going on in the Milberg
Weiss firm it takes him seven years to
get to the bottom of this so I mean it's
hard work that the SEC has to dip
point well-taken but what I and and I
didn't mean it and I don't mean to be
overly critical of that agency but let
me rephrase that someone the the
enforcement arm of the federal
government I'm talking about the Justice
Department the SEC and in other entities
that are related just didn't do haven't
done a good enough job of making this
fraud not pay that's so that's what
that's what that's what larec would say
it's what I say and it's what Pat Dylan
would say they just haven't and I don't
know what that takes you know Burning
Man I was gonna be a prison the rest of
his life you think that would be a
deterrent effect I don't know maybe it
will maybe they've started to do some of
this but in the period we were talking
about leading up to this leading up to
this bubble clearly there were thousands
of people on Wall Street and you've seen
these guys from Goldman Sachs they come
down testify they're barely contrite
who who treat it like it's a game
corporate capitalism looks to an
increasingly number of Americans like an
insider's game something that you can
fix and rigged and that's the government
has not done a good enough job making
that not be the case and not seen the
case so that's that's one that's one
part but it is it isn't a sense I mean
it's tough it's a tough challenge for
the government because you have
multimillionaires at Wall Street you
have CEOs that are getting compensation
packages that are eye-popping
and you have the Builder racks of the
world that are looking over the Pacific
Ocean in their multi multi-million
dollar mansions and then you have career
government lawyers at the SEC that are
getting paid $100,000 a year which might
sound like good
to some of our listeners but just pales
in comparison so it is a difficult
dynamic for the government sureness and
I also submit that the court the Supreme
Court didn't help well let's talk about
that because that's where I make my
cameo in the book but what did the
Supreme Court do to to get involved I
mean you know Bill Iraq seems like a
trial lawyer doesn't seem like the kind
of lawyer that's going to spend a lot of
time in the Supreme Court but the
Supreme Court ends up figuring fairly
prominently toward the toward the end of
the book the Supreme Court decided in a
case that you know a lot better than I
do in two cases really a case called
central bank and then a case called
Stone Ridge they made it more difficult
to sue third-party fraudsters is that
the right word third-party actors a turd
and abettor aiders and it is a legal
term there you go the the the
accountants who told these the corporate
thieves yeah you could do that that'll
work knowing it wouldn't know what it
shouldn't
how's that for breaking it down into
them dick Harwood the great Washington
Post editor said let's put it down there
where the goats can get it well the
court said and I don't if they seem to
follow your reasoning Paul and a brief
you wrote that if Congress wanted to do
that they could they took it and what I
say do that I mean allow you to sue
third-party ators know better so you
don't always been able to do that up
until the central bank case suddenly you
can't and this figures in our book
because it affects all these Enron
mainly but other cases
WorldCom Halliburton know this is a big
part of the law because the company
that's gone bankrupt is bankrupt but
what about a this huge what about the
banks what about the County firms that
allowed them to pull off these
shenanigans this slate of hand these
bookkeeping slate of hands that misled
investors so that you have all right
back to my original thing you have the
federal government despite how very
difficult it is for SEC lawyers in the
like not not able to keep up with
corporate fraud you've got the Supreme
Court making it tougher to sue aiders
and abetters you've got an executive
branch that's term including when Bill
Clinton's president so not just a
Democrat Republican things sorry I'm
marginally interested in this issue
at all and what you have left is these
is these lawyers suing and their
imperfect system in their system that's
getting them rich but the plaintiffs you
know the investors they're not
complaining they're happy their thing at
least we got something and maybe some of
it's cathartic maybe some of it's maybe
there's a deterrent effect maybe they're
getting a little bit a lot less than
they'd like but in the end they had a
role to play and Bill the rack was was
their star sure sure but as you say I
mean unlike the Shawn coffees of the
world who played by the rules and it's
kind of one of the new stars of the of
the class action bar you know bill bill
crossed some lines in the process of
doing this and I think I mean you know I
think you would say that Bill Iraq is a
fascinating character he is fascinating
in part because he's complex he was a
great fighter of fraud but in the
process committed fraud himself so I
think I mean I don't want to put words
in your mouth but but I don't think you
come away from this book certainly there
as a reader I didn't thinking well you
know build Iraq as a hero and I guess
what I'd ask you I mean do you agree
with that and are there any heroes in
this book in the 1970s you know the
movies bill and I lived in Southern
California were fooled anti-heroes that
was the thing of the of the day when I
met bill he's in a way an antihero but
he's also he's the protagonist of the
story he's he's the one
he's a flawed flawed guy he's Icarus
he's he does he does he lose his way
that's the question we raised I think we
let the reader answer it for him or
herself if you're asking me my own view
out we I think we were tough on Bill on
his business model he's the crimes
shortly well I think we were pretty
clear eyed about that on the bigger
picture the stuff things you and I are
talking about now whether he helped the
system whether whether he had a role to
play that was that the public needs
whether corporate capitalism is broken
and without crusading lawyers like Bill
Dirac and Sean Coffey the thing can't be
fixed I think we gave him you say I
think we gave them his due on that we
don't
we don't exactly come down aside with
him but we quote him and we quote him
we let him on that point I think he has
I think he has an argument sure but when
the epilogue places them in the federal
penitentiary it's hard to think that
maybe he didn't lose his way somewhere
in in in in the course of the book and
there are as you mentioned there other
plaintiffs lawyers that managed to fight
fraud without violating the laws and
committing fraud themselves and I'm just
wondering I mean are there are there any
heroes in this book in your mind you
know I look Sean coffees beyond reproach
in my view and how about the prosecutor
and well I was going to say there can't
you know if the guys their white hat
guys at Robinson and his team and
Virginia curry the agent FBI you know
who delved into that these are these
quiet unsung bureaucrats is what they
are you know making a government salary
and I think they didn't they didn't lose
their way mm-hmm
no it's interesting well let me ask you
one other question about the book
because one of the things I found so
fascinating about this book is that on
the one hand you have this great story
about Bill Iraq in the process you tell
a story about a very important part of
the legal world in terms of the rise and
fall of securities class action the acts
of Congress the acts of the Supreme
Court but then in the middle of this
book you also have something that I mean
you know although this is a book of
nonfiction it seems like it's taken from
the pages of some you know great
thriller novel where you know that
basically bill Iraq's whole kingdom sort
of comes unraveled because of a domestic
dispute in Cleveland now I don't want
you to give away the book necessarily
but can you talk a little bit just about
the kind of kind of the the whodunit
aspect of this book well how did the
what look one of their stalking horses
that guy mentioned before Steve
Cooperman is and we a the characters you
know look anybody's ever covered courts
as I did Criminal Courts I mean he's a
tight but he's the most spectacular
example the type he is a born grifter he
his mind oh you know the phrase a guy
has a criminal mind he automatically
sees the grift he sees the angle and so
he was getting 10% kickbacks he was a
professional clan of plaintiff or Billa
right but he had all kinds of other
scams going on simultaneously he was he
was defrauding his insurance company
from prison he he stole art he he stole
his own art and then built the insurance
company when they balked at painting
because they could see what it was an
inside job he sued them and won and he
went through millions and millions of
dollars and but one of the pictures but
when he was finally caught and it looked
like he was maybe gonna have to spend
the rest of his life in prison he said
seeing the angle as he always did I
could tell you about this what if I told
you about this law firm mm-hmm and a law
firm it was Milburn Weiss and the guy he
and the guys he knew were male and Pihl
and he knew Billy had dinner with him
they'd set up a deal it's a you know if
people have told me you know that the
books they couldn't put it down and
that's a compliment and your friends say
that you don't know if they're just
being nice to you but but I have to tell
you if that's true in our antihero gets
some of the credit for that as well he's
a he's a guy that he's like if Forrest
Gump was not slow but very smart he has
the star-crossed life I mean point in
our book you know he handled the Keating
five plaintiffs and sued on behalf and
sued Charlie Keating and Lincoln savings
and at one point bringing a sort of
gross publicity stunt that works beyond
anybody's wildest imaginations brings
these elderly people back and Hamlisch
as these senators and they reveal their
character
very meets them but is very guarded
don't meet them at all John McCain gets
on his knees and begged their
forgiveness later in the book when when
Bill's trying to get Clinton to veto the
PSLRA for actually he's trying to bribe
the president he gives him all this
money then tells him to veto the thing
and Clinton keeps his distance somewhat
but but he's there's all these stories
in it that you couldn't you couldn't
have made up now one one one question I
wanted to ask you is I guess some
football tickets figure prominently in
the epilogue but I'm a big believer and
I think you are from your tie then it
all comes back from baseball so is there
a baseball angle on this book is there a
moral for us baseball fans in this book
you know Paul let me just leave look on
this note because it's a serious note
even though yes alight question bill
that bill had this gang of boys he
played baseball with this his older
brother and a couple of cousins and a
kid named Ginny Jean Carney and Jean
went away to to become a priest and then
and then live this full life and then
became late in life a baseball writer
reinvented himself and and wrote not
bestsellers but first straight baseball
books baseball scholars have told me
that genes books were very very good and
he was helpful to me and he's the kind
of guy so careful with the truth you
sent him an email he corrects your
spelling in the email and some little
fact that you might have wrong in a very
careful guy and he helped me and he
talked in bringing bills life in
Pittsburgh to life that those those
years and the bills family and gene died
just before the book went to press and I
you know I never met him in person but
he convinced me the truth of what you're
saying I mean people who really know
baseball are salt of the earth that's
the truth that's truth let me ask you
one last question maybe the last
question which is this this is a great
read you cover a lot of territory you
spend a lot of time with Bill Iraq you
had incredible access to him up to
including the time that he spent in the
federal penitentiary what are the
conclusions you draw from from from this
book look you go out to right or wrong
you got to be careful you do have to be
careful you don't come with you become
while you despise and you make enemies
you know you mentioned baseball this
perfect game the other day
taken away by an umpire but the umpire
is not he's sort of he's weathered it
he's not people like him more than they
did before people even knowing before
the players haven't turned against him
the writer 7 why is that because he had
a good reputation because for 20 years
look on the biggest night of his life is
enough he blew the biggest call of his
career sure blew it inexplicable but for
20 years he did a good job not a great
job a good job players liked him and
they respected him and he liked the
players and he respected the game and
that's why he weathered what I mean a
moral of this story in life as well as
in circle of greed is that we are were
judged by our actions for for better or
worse and bill bills bill did some very
good things and he did some things that
were not good and he's he's being judged
by the totality of it and would we be
better off today with with with with
bill out of prison I mean now he's out
of prison is this gonna is this going to
help get us get fraud out of the the
system maybe I'm going soft on you Paul
but I think so I think he has something
to say and I think and I'm for one
intend to listen great well thank you
Carl it's been a great conversation
thank you